We trust experts, but that doesn't always
work out, especially in the field of
education policy. Back in 2001, Congress
passed the No Child Left Behind Act. Set
the ambitious goal that a hundred
percent of our nation's students would
be reading and doing math on grade level
by 2014. Didn't work out. We didn't even
come close, but along the way we actually
did some real harm. Schools got over-focused
on testing; kids got caught up in
drill-and-kill assignment; and parents got
concerned that schools forgot a lot of
what matters for a kid's education. Or take
the Obama administration's School
Improvement Grants program. Seven billion
dollars later, a 2017 federal evaluation
found that the program made no
difference for kids in participating
schools. Expertise has a role to play, but
experts only know a little bit about
what actually goes on in complicated
schools and among the complexities of
education policy. That's why you'd do well
to take advice from any of us experts
with more than a few grains of salt.
To learn more about my take on school
reform, check the links in the
description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like AEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds.